katie it's so wonderful to see you are
you
ready to share your journey with the
world on finding love
i'm so ready
i'm looking forward to i think so many
people are so blink twice if you are in
love
i can't have analyzing anything come on
believe twice if you're engaged i can't
i can't
my eyes are watering i'm trying here i
know so many people are looking forward
to this season
because they absolutely love you and i
gotta say it was pretty cool to see
the premiere and the of you and that red
dress standing next to
caitlyn and tasha how were they as
mentor i mean what was the best advice
they gave you about
experiencing this 100 percent i mean
they just told me
to really you know surrender to the
process let go of control
and that was probably the hardest thing
i did but once i really did that
that's when the good stuff starts to
happen and there's a lot of good stuff
in the preview because there are some
hot moments that we see and
i think there's like this the notebook
moment where you're in the rain
i think it's greg i mean you're living
it you're living this moment i mean how
does it feel to be on the other side
is it more of an emotional roller
coaster yeah you know you think you know
what to expect
uh because you've gone through it before
but it's it's nothing you could ever
really be prepared for so you're just
taking it day by day
i love that and did you have any
hesitation after last season on taking
on
the bachelorette or was it a yes right
away there was definitely some thought
put into it you know it is a big
decision
um and you're opening yourself up to the
entire world to watch you and
essentially criticize you but ultimately
this was the best choice for me
i love that and also the fact that yeah
the last few seasons there's been a lot
of changes happening talking about the
lack of diversity
what have you done this season and was
it important for you to see
representation
yeah my uh group of men are very diverse
and it's important that their stories
are shared
and i'm hoping that that's displayed as
we go forward i think these guys have a
lot to open up about and i'm just
excited for everyone to get to meet them
and on top of changes we saw chris
harrison not uh part of bachelor in
paradise this season what did you feel
about that
i mean i'm not even focused on paradise
at the moment you know for me
i had caitlyn and tasha help me through
my journey and it was
better than i could have ever expected
do you want chris to come back to the
franchise
that's really a decision between him and
the franchise you know i can only speak
to what i experienced which was with
caitlyn tasha and it worked really well
for me
that's great i love to hear that and the
fact is when you were on the season with
matt i mean there was that epic moment
right off the top
with your you know your sense of just
being happy with your vibrator i'm
assuming you left it at home
yeah yeah that's the goal right i hope
you never have to use it anymore
i don't put it here right 2020 compared
to 2021.
uh how would you describe this season in
just a few words
i mean it's a wild ride really
and for you what did you learn about
yourself through this process compared
to last time
i think for me i have to actually watch
this back because in the moment
there's so many emotions going on and
you're kind of living in this moment
i feel like when i watch this back i
will learn more about myself going
forward
mm-hmm and did you love the experience
i mean it's a hard experience you know
but you hope to find love and i
i did more than once that's what i'll
say to that
and when you're surrounded by so many
men did you learn something new about
the other sex
i mean you definitely learn a lot about
these guys for sure
yeah and so uh we're looking forward to
this season
i'm you look like you had a great time
it looks like you're happy
right right always happy
you're not giving me anything katie
you're amazing congratulations and we're
looking forward to seeing tonight and
i hope you had a great time thank you so
much
thank you katie take care
you